This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On a Friday evening in the summer of 2011, Los Angeles resident Brent Green was driving home from work. He was coming from a job site and took a route he doesn't usually take to get to his neighborhood. And I might not have come this way. I mean, I'm glad I did because when I saw this, I knew that it was a problem and I got out of my car.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2011年夏天的一个周五傍晚，洛杉矶居民布伦特·格林正开车下班回家。他当时正从一个工作地点离开，为了回社区，走了一条他平时不常走的路。我可能本来不会走这条路。我是说，我很高兴我走了这条路，因为当我看到这个情景时，我知道出问题了，于是我下了车。
What did you see? That's our producer Sam Greenspan. He met with Brent in Los Angeles. I saw about 25 to 30 guys with heavy equipment, all wearing orange jumpsuits, they had backhows, they had trencher, trenching machines, I mean like large tractor material, they were like stuff that you can't just like ignore. You and I might not think there's anything weird about a bunch of guys doing work on a freeway berm, but Brent took one look and thought,
你看到了什么？那是我们的制作人萨姆·格林斯潘。他在洛杉矶见到了布伦特。我看到大约有25到30个人带着重型设备，全都穿着橙色连体服，他们有反铲挖土机，有挖沟机，我是说就像大型拖拉机那样的设备，那是你无法忽视的东西。你和我可能不会觉得一群人在高速公路路堤上施工有什么奇怪的，但布伦特看了一眼就想：
well, this all seems kind of fishy. For starters, it seemed late for a city work crew to be doing landscaping. And I said, that's odd, that's almost seven o'clock. They're not even out here at seven o'clock. So what are they doing? They gotta be up to something. The crew was manicuring some trees And I said that's odd, that's almost seven o'clock. They're not even out here at seven o'clock. So what are they doing? They got me up to something.
嗯，这一切看起来有点可疑。首先，城市施工队在这个时间进行园林绿化似乎太晚了。我说，这很奇怪，都快七点钟了。他们甚至不在这个点出来。那他们在干什么？他们肯定在搞什么鬼。施工队在修剪一些树木。我说这很奇怪，都快七点钟了。他们甚至不在这个点出来。那他们在干什么？他们肯定在搞什么鬼。
The crew was manicuring some trees and a fenced off piece of land next to a freeway, in what had long been a low income neighborhood. It's a patch of land that never gets landscape. The only reason the trees were there was because about 40 years ago, some birds flew over and pooped out fertilized seeds. And no one ever touched them. It's not like they're just cleaning the tree up to make it look better on the tree, we're
施工队在高速公路旁一块有围栏的土地上修剪一些树木，这片土地长期以来一直是低收入社区。这是一块从不进行绿化的土地。这些树之所以存在，只是因为大约40年前，一些鸟儿飞过并排下了带有受精种子的粪便。而且从来没有人动过它们。这可不是说他们只是在清理树木，让树看起来更好看，我们
looking at all the rest of them, they all look like crap. And that's when Brent put it together, a work crew doing an after hours landscaping job in an area where they never do any work to Brent this meant one thing. I know with all my being that they're taking the trees. Oh, legally stealing trees. Now, the reason that Brent Green was able to to do so all of this is because he is by trade a landscape designer. And so he knew the worth of the trees that the work crew had been messing with. I've actually purchased these trees for projects and they're like 20
在看其他所有树，它们看起来都像垃圾一样糟。就在那时，布伦特把这些线索串联起来了，一个施工队在他们从不工作的地区加班进行园林绿化工作，对布伦特来说这意味着一件事。我全身心地知道他们在偷树。哦，合法偷树。现在，布伦特·格林能够发现这一切的原因是，他的职业是一名景观设计师。因此，他知道施工队一直在摆弄的那些树的价值。我实际上为项目买过这些树，它们价值大约2
grand. $20,000 a tree. Brent confronted the workers and asked them what they were doing. Some of them took off running. Later a woman who lives on that street came down from her apartment and Brenaster if she knew what was going on. She said, honey, baby, they didn't just take that one. They're not taking, they took like six other ones. They took two over there, four over there. They've been here all week. I'm like, really, you know, then I called the police. This is not the first case in Palm Thaft. Palm Ruslin has been reported in Texas and San Diego,
万美元。一棵树2万美元。布伦特与工人们对质，问他们在干什么。其中几个人跑掉了。后来，住在街上的一个女人从她的公寓下来，布伦特问她是否知道发生了什么。她说，亲爱的，宝贝，他们拿走的不仅是那一棵。他们不只是在拿，他们还拿了大约其他六棵。那边拿了两棵，那边拿了四棵。他们这周一直都在这儿。我说，真的吗，你知道的，然后我报警了。这不是棕榈树盗窃案的唯一案例。在德克萨斯州和圣迭戈都有过棕榈树被盗的报道，
it even gets a mention in Susan Orleans book, The Orchid Teve. And to understand why someone would want to steal a palm tree, we need to really understand their value, which has a lot to do with the space they occupy in our collective imagination. And for that, we need to talk to this guy. My name is Jared Farmer.
它甚至在苏珊·奥尔林的书中被提及过，也就是《兰花贼》。要理解为什么会有人想要偷一棵棕榈树，我们需要真正了解它们的价值，这在很大程度上与它们在我们集体想象中所占据的空间有关。为此，我们需要和这个人聊聊。我叫贾里德·法默。
I am the author of Trees in Paradise, a California history. It is book, Jared Farmer traces the history of the Golden State through four kinds of trees, one of them being the Palm. The others are the Redwood, the Citrus, and the Eucalypt. Though we should get this out of the way first. A palm tree isn't really a tree.
我是《天堂里的树木：加利福尼亚史》一书的作者。在这本书中，贾里德·法默通过四种树木追溯了黄金时代的历史，其中一种就是棕榈树。其他三种是红木、柑橘和桉树。虽然我们首先得把这个说清楚。棕榈树其实并不是一棵真正的树。
It's actually not a tree. It's kind of like grass. It's like a super grass. It's like hundreds or thousands of these like long blades of grass in a sense like fuse together. Palm trees don't make bark or branches. If you cut them down, you won't find any rings in the trunk. All their roots grow in a compact root ball, making them easier to steal than say like
它其实不是一棵树。它有点像草。它就像一种超级草。从某种意义上说，它就像成百上千根长长的草叶融合在一起。棕榈树不产生树皮或树枝。如果你把它们砍倒，你在树干里找不到任何年轮。它们所有的根都生长在一个紧凑的根球中，这使得它们比方说
an oak tree which has an expansive underground root network. And as far as trees go, we don't plant palms for any of the normal reasons we want other trees around. It's not for the shade, it's not for climbing. You can't really climb a palm tree very well, that it casts precious little shade. Palm trees, it seems, do something else. They're evocative. They're trans well, they cast precious little shade. Palm trees, it seems, do something else. They're evocative. They're transportative.
橡树更容易被偷，橡树拥有庞大的地下根系。就树木而言，我们种植棕榈树并不是出于我们想要其他树木存在时的任何正常原因。不是为了遮阴，不是为了攀爬。你其实没法很好地爬棕榈树，它投下的阴凉微乎其微。棕榈树似乎有别的作用。它们能唤起回忆。它们能带——嗯，它们投下的阴凉微乎其微。棕榈树似乎有别的作用。它们能唤起回忆。它们具有移情作用。
They inspire us to dream big. It's about image, imbueding, and fashion, and design, and sometimes about architecture. Palms, especially urban palms in places like Los Angeles, are planted less for what they do than what they mean, or rather what they mean is what they do. If you trace the history of what palm trees have symbolized in the Western imagination, as Jared Farmer has, you start to get the idea that palm trees have always been about
它们激励我们胸怀大志。这关乎形象、氛围、时尚、设计，有时也关乎建筑。棕榈树，尤其是像洛杉矶这样的地方的城市棕榈树，人们种植它们，与其说是为了它们的功能，不如说是为了它们的寓意，或者更准确地说，它们的寓意就是它们的功能。如果你像贾里德·法默那样，追溯棕榈树在西方想象中所象征的历史，你就会开始明白，棕榈树一直以来都旨在
evoking a spirit of elsewhere. Even 200 years ago, palm trees were planted in California by the Spanish as a way of signifying on the Holy Land. Orthodox Christianity and Roman Catholicism often demands actually having fronds, and that's the reason the Spanish in California grew palm trees just to have palms for Palm Sunday. So palm trees were around by the time that California became a state in 1850, and around that same time, there was a trend in art and literature of what we now call orientalism,
唤起一种异国他乡的精神。甚至在200年以前，加利福尼亚的西班牙人就种植棕榈树，以此来象征圣地。东正教和罗马天主教通常确实需要棕榈叶，这就是加利福尼亚的西班牙人种植棕榈树的原因，只是为了在棕榈主日时有棕榈叶可用。因此，当加利福尼亚在1850年成为一个州时，棕榈树就已经存在了，大约在同一时期，艺术和文学界出现了一种潮流，也就是我们现在所说的东方主义，
a kind of fascination with the East. Sort of that fantasy of like, Arabs and better ones and Oasis and Sahara Zadda kind of thing. And so palm trees dovetailed quite nicely with those kinds of fascinations. Palm trees were also used to make people think of the tropics.
一种对东方的迷恋。某种关于阿拉伯人、贝都因人、绿洲和撒哈拉沙漠的幻想之类的东西。因此，棕榈树与这种迷恋非常吻合。棕榈树也被用来让人联想到热带地区。
And while these three tropes are unfolding, palm trees symbolizing the holy land, the orient, the tropics, they also kind of do this thing where they all congeal and collapse into a bigger notion that we can still recognize today. Palm trees is a symbol for luxury and leisure. So by like 1900, if you went to say San Francisco to Union Square or if you went to Manhattan or to Paris or to London or you know World City in the West you would find a palm court in the hotel Even the RMS Titanic at a palm court even though palms were already going international by the dawn of the 20th century It was in California around Los Angeles especially especially, that their place in the global
正当这三个比喻——棕榈树象征圣地、东方、热带——展开的同时，它们也以某种方式融合并坍缩成了一个更大的概念，我们今天依然能识别出来：棕榈树是奢华和休闲的象征。因此，大约到了1900年，如果你去圣弗朗西斯科的联合广场，或者去曼哈顿、巴黎、伦敦，或者西方任何一个世界城市，你会在酒店里发现一个棕榈庭院。甚至泰坦尼克号上也有一个棕榈庭院。尽管早在20世纪初，棕榈树就已经走向国际化，但正是在加利福尼亚，特别是在洛杉矶周围，它们在全球
imagination really took root. Oh, God. A trend emerged among homeowners of planting palm trees on either side of their front door. At first, this was only a thing that wealthy people did. But at some point, you're not rich. You just have a little starter bungalow in L.A. but like, you got palm trees too. That really did sort of signify you have achieved not just the American dream, but the California version of the American dream,
想象中的地位才真正扎下了根。天哪。房主中间兴起了一种潮流，在他们前门的左右两边各种一棵棕榈树。起初，这只是有钱人才做的事。但不知何时，你不再是有钱人了。你只是在洛杉矶有一个小小的入门级平房，但你也种了棕榈树。这确实在某种程度上象征着你不仅实现了美国梦，还实现了美国梦的加利福尼亚版本，
which was everything the American dream offer, but also great weather, gorgeous setting, trees that flower smell good, and look good every month of the year. And while this trend is taking off, something happens in the rich suburbs outside of LA. In towns like Redlands and Riverside, which were then super affluent, people there started planting palms not just on private property, but also along city streets.
那就是美国梦所能提供的一切，还有棒极了的天气、绚丽的环境、一年四季开花、气味芬芳且外表美观的树木。正当这股潮流兴起时，洛杉矶郊外的富裕住宅区发生了一些变化。在雷德兰兹和里弗赛德等当时超级富裕的城镇，那里的人们开始在私人领地种植棕榈树，也开始在城市街道两旁种植。
It's about really what I would call the municipal palm, a palm that symbolizes the city itself and symbolizes good life in the city. Eventually Los Angeles proper got hip to this idea of municipal trees and during the Great Depression, the works progress administration put a lot of unemployment to work planting trees throughout the city. There are more than 2,500 species of palm tree, but as palm trees flourished in California,
这实际上关乎我所说的城市棕榈树，一种象征城市本身并象征城市美好生活的棕榈树。最终，洛杉矶市区也接受了这种城市树木的理念，在大萧条时期，公共事业振兴署安排了大量失业人员在整个城市到处种植树木。棕榈树的种类有2500多种，但随着棕榈树在加利福尼亚蓬勃发展，
there's one particular species that stood out. The Canary Island date palm, or Phoenix Canaryensis. Yeah, they're probably the most spectacular palm in the world, I want to say, in terms of the number of fronds, the width of the fronds, and it has a kind of bumpy, cross hatched trunk from when the fronds, and it has a kind of bumpy, cross hatched trunk from when the fronds detach. The Phoenix Canaryensis is so stately and majestic that it was used as the symbol of California boosterism at the turn of the century. One Phoenix was even dug up, put on a rail car, and freighted all the way to Chicago for the
有一种特定的品种脱颖而出。加那利海枣，或称加那利海枣（Phoenix canariensis）。是的，我想可以说它们是世界上最壮观的棕榈树，就棕榈叶的数量、棕榈叶的宽度而言，而且当棕榈叶脱落时，它有一种 bumpy（凹凸不平的）、交叉孵化的树干，当棕榈叶脱落时，它有一种凹凸不平的、交叉孵化的树干。加那利海枣如此庄严宏伟，以至于在世纪之交被用作加利福尼亚自我宣传（boosterism）的象征。甚至有一棵加那利海枣被挖出来，装上铁路线车厢，一路货运到芝加哥参加
1893 Colombian exposition. And every day on the trunk, California boosters would put up a piece of paper that listed the temperature at Coronado Beach at San Diego and at Lake Michigan, just for comparison. Us Californians have always been dicks about our weather. After the exposition, the palm tree was sent back to California. Obviously, it wasn't going to be left to suffer in the frigid city of Chicago. Can you imagine?
1893年的哥伦比亚博览会。加利福尼亚的宣传人员每天都在树干上贴一张纸，上面列出圣迭戈科罗纳多海滩和密歇根湖的温度，只是为了进行比较。我们加利福尼亚人对于我们的天气一向都很傲慢。博览会结束后，这棵棕榈树被送回了加利福尼亚。显然，它不可能被留在冰冷的芝加哥城里受苦。你能想象吗？
The horror! This is me being a dick about our weather. For a long time, the Phoenix Canariancy was mostly a symbol of Southern California. But eventually, especially by the 1990s, they were also in hot demand up north in the Bay area. And since the Phoenix Canariancy takes 50 to 60 years to mature, tree nurseries couldn't keep up with the demand. You just can't manufacture more 50-year-old palm trees.
太可怕了！这是我在对我们的天气表现得傲慢。很长一段时间里，加那利海枣主要只是南加利福尼亚的象征。但最终，特别是到了20世纪90年代，湾区北部对它们的渴求也达到了白热化。由于加那利海枣需要50到60年才能成熟，苗圃根本无法满足需求。你就是无法批量生产50年树龄的棕榈树。
So there are people called palm brokers. They go to older residential neighborhoods where people have like a little bungalow. They're like the third generation in that bungalow. They now have this, you know this 80-foot palm tree. They might have some sentimental attachment to it, but it's actually not doing much for them, and someone offers them a few hundred dollars for it, and they'll take it off their hands,
所以出现了一些被称为棕榈树经纪人的人。他们去到较老的住宅区，那里的人们住着小平房。他们就像是那个平房里的第三代。他们现在有了这个，你知道的，这个80英尺高的棕榈树。他们可能对它有一些情感依恋，但它实际上对他们没有太大用处，然后有人出几百美元买下它，他们就会把它转手卖掉，
and many people take that opportunity, especially in a time of recession. The Canary Island date palm craze has died down a little, but they're still in high demand. And between the demand, the time it takes for a treatumature and the sheer heft of moving these things. The Phoenix Canarynsis is the most expensive palm tree to buy. The going price, including a truck to move it,
许多人都抓住了这个机会，尤其是在经济衰退时期。加那利海枣的热潮已经稍微消退了一点，但它们的需求量仍然很大。考虑到需求、树木成熟所需的时间以及搬迁这些庞然大物的巨大分量，加那利海枣是购买成本最高的棕榈树。市价包括运送它的卡车、
a crane to lift it, and a crew to plant it. It's a lot of money. 20 grand of a tree. Yes, again, $20,000 a tree. And that is why, to bring us back to our earlier story, Angelino Brent Green was so outraged when he saw that work crew in his neighborhood that summer night in 2011. They were there, Brent believes, to steal more than $100,000 worth of palm trees. Brent reported what he saw to the police, also got the local NBC affiliate on the trail.
吊起它的起重机以及种植它的施工队。这是一大笔钱。一棵树2万美元。是的，再说一次，一棵树2万美元。这就是为什么，回到我们之前的故事，2011年那个夏天的夜晚，当洛杉矶人布伦特·格林看到他社区里的那个施工队时，他会如此愤怒。布伦特认为，他们出现在那里，是为了盗取价值超过10万美元的棕榈树。布伦特向警方报告了他所看到的情况，还将当地的全国广播公司（NBC）分支机构也吸引来追踪报道。
And our investigation has found this could be an inside job. We found at least one CalTrans official could be involved in these thefts. Long story short, an employee at the California Department of Transportation had signed off on a work order, allowing a third party to go in and remove the trees. A lawsuit followed, one result of which was six Canary Island date palms getting put back on the freeway berm in Brent's neighborhood. And anyway, it might not matter too much in the grand scheme of things, because the tree scape of Los Angeles is about to have a lot fewer palm trees to steal.
我们的调查发现，这可能是一起内部作案。我们发现至少有一名加州交通局（CalTrans）的官员可能卷入了这些盗窃案。简而言之，加利福尼亚州交通局的一名员工签署了一份工作订单，允许第三方进入并移除这些树木。随后发生了一场诉讼，其中一个结果是六棵加那利海枣被重新种回了布伦特社区的高速公路路堤上。不管怎样，从宏观角度来看，这可能并不是太重要，因为洛杉矶的树木景观里将很快少很多可供偷窃的棕榈树。
A fungus called Fusarium Wilt has been rampantly killing off certain species of palm trees, including the Phoenix Canaryensis. In fact, several different landscape designers told me that they avoid using the Phoenix Canaryensis palms right now because of their susceptibility to the will. And on top of that, as of 2006, the city of Los Angeles has greatly curbed its replanting of fan palms. Those are the really tall, spindly guys with the skinny trunks. A motion approved by the City Council stated that fan palms don't provide adequate
一种叫做镰刀菌枯萎病（Fusarium Wilt）的真菌一直在疯狂杀死某些种类的棕榈树，包括加那利海枣。事实上，几位不同的景观设计师告诉我，他们现在避免使用加那利海枣，因为它们对这种枯萎病毫无抵抗力。最重要的是，自2006年以来，洛杉矶市已经大幅减少了扇叶棕榈的重新种植。那些是树干很细、非常高且瘦长的家伙。市议会批准的一项动议指出，扇叶棕榈无法提供充足的
tree cover, they don't release enough oxygen into the atmosphere, and they shed so many fronds that they are considered hazardous. All the palm trees that got planted in the teens, 20s, and 30s are all going to be dying of old age in the next few decades. And without them getting replanted, palms will largely disappear from the Los Angeles streetscape. Though of course palm trees will still get replanted in the iconic spots where people expect palm trees to be. Designated tour zones like Hollywood and sunset boulevards where they will always be because
树荫，它们没有向大气中释放足够的氧气，而且它们脱落的棕榈叶如此之多，以至于被认为具有危险性。在十几岁、20年代和30年代种植的所有棕榈树都将在未来几十年内因年老而逐渐死亡。如果没有对它们进行重新种植，棕榈树将在很大程度上从洛杉矶的街景中消失。当然，棕榈树仍会被重新种植在人们期望看到棕榈树的标志性地点。像好莱坞和日落大道这样的指定旅游区，它们将永远在那里，因为
tourists expect them to be there because that is what LA is supposed to look like. But Jared Farmer is actually not too sad to see the palms of Southern California go. Mind you, this is a guy who writes about trees for a living and is a self-proclaimed lover of palms. In a time of less water, more people, I think we have to make wiser choices about the kind of trees we use. And California will still happen incredibly diverse tree skate. But a Los Angeles without palm trees?
游客期望它们在那里，因为那是洛杉矶应有的样子。但贾里德·法默对于南加利福尼亚的棕榈树消逝其实并不是太伤心。请记住，这是一个以写树木为生、自称是棕榈树爱好者的人。在水资源减少、人口增多的时代，我认为我们必须对我们所使用的树木种类做出更明智的选择。加利福尼亚仍然会有极其多样化的树木景观。但是，一个没有棕榈树的洛杉矶？
Not on Brent Green's watch anyway. He told me that when he was a kid, he used to draw houses with palm trees next to them, and now that he's grown up, he's fulfilled his own California-American dream. Though his house is a modest bungalow, it's made so much more stately by the ten or so palms in front of his home. And even knowing everything I know about palms that they were basically marketing tools and how they played at this phony sense of exoticism,
无论如何，在布伦特·格林的监督下是绝对不行的。他告诉我，他小时候经常画旁边有棕榈树的房子，现在他长大了，他实现了自己的加利福尼亚-美国梦。虽然他的房子是一个简朴的平房，但由于他家门前大约有十棵棕榈树，它变得庄严宏伟了许多。即使了解了我所知道关于棕榈树的一切——它们基本上是营销工具，以及它们如何迎合这种虚假的异国情调感，
I have to say, it all still kinda works on me. I found myself in awe and a little jealous of Brent's California dream. And I've got palm trees now. It's also very proud of I love my palm trees. 99% invisible was produced this week by Sam Greenspan with Katie Mingle, Avery Troubleman and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Cindy Gilliland, Jason Dewey's, Darren Sears and Tom Driesbach.
我必须说，这一切对我都还是挺管用的。我发现自己对布伦特对加利福尼亚梦感到敬畏又有点嫉妒。我现在也有棕榈树了。它也令人非常自豪，我爱我的棕榈树。本周的 99% Invisible 由萨姆·格林斯潘制作，凯蒂·明格、艾弗里·特拉布曼和我罗曼·马尔斯共同参与。特别感谢辛迪·吉利兰、杰森·杜伊、达伦·西尔斯和汤姆·德里斯巴赫。
We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxine, in architecture and interior's farm, in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, we're all on Twitter and Instagram, Tumblr and Spotify, but I encourage you to explore the entire world of 99% invisible at 99pi.org.
我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州美丽奥克兰市中心的一家建筑与室内设计公司 Arxine 的办公室。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并关注这个节目，我们也在 Twitter、Instagram、Tumblr 和 Spotify 上，但我鼓励你在 99pi.org 上探索 99% Invisible 的整个世界。
Radio Topeo from PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX 的 Radio Bilingüe。你还没有针对本集的评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。